[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 60,18 bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez dans cette édition
d'information locale voici les titres de
ce lundi 14 septembre
en cette rentrée les étudiants aussi
sont de retour à l'université après de
longs mois de fermeture a lu vs q les
cours reprenaient aujourd'hui à la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques comment l'établissement
s'organise en plein contexte épidémique
reportage trois jours consacrée à la
petite reine le vélo club de montigny le
bretonneux organisait sa traditionnelle
fête de vendredi à dimanche au programme
redd en vtt et course sur les routes de
la vallée de chevreuse retour sur
l'événement
et puis la page dédiée à la législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines premier tour dimanche 20
septembre
onze candidats sont sur la ligne de
départ dont sandrine grand gambe pour
génération et europe ecologie les verts
elle est notre invité et puis tout à
l'heure également le retour sur la fête
médiévale qui s'est tenue à maurepas ce
week end
cette chaleur bien inhabituel d'abord
pour ce mois de septembre le thermomètre
a grimpé au dessus des 30 degrés
aujourd'hui des températures élevées qui
vont se poursuivre tout au long de la
semaine
le niveau 2 du plan alerte canicule a
été d'ailleurs activé dans les yvelines
entre plaisir de prolonger l'été et
inquiétude pour la planète les gluants
courtois se sont confiés ce micro ce
midi au micro d' astrid berges r&d
l'honneur sinoquet alors bas côté ça
fait du bien mais armement se dit que si
la planète va bien s'il fait 30° au mois
de septembre et et qu'il faut faire
quelque chose pour la planète c'est
sympa on peut on peut aller manger
dehors prendre du temps avec les amis
c'est très agréable surtout en ces temps
de rentrée là c'est très agréable de
voir se promener et profiter un peu
avant la phase de l'hiver qui va être
longue on est bien dehors mais après
c'est vraiment préoccupant pour la
planète toussaint et faut faire beaucoup
de choses quand même pour changer tout
ça ça va pas des plus agréable de manger
dehors que l'intérieur ça peut oublier
la rentrée d'habitude on sort plutôt les
parapluies les aider les imperméables à
ses côtés si ça peut arriver
donc c'est plus agréable de prolonger
l'été et avec ces fortes températures
pensez à vous hydrater régulièrement à
mouiller votre corps et avoue ventilé
éviter les efforts physiques et en cas
de malaise composer le 15
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était la rentrée
universitaire pour mille étudiants de la
faculté de droit et de science politique
de l'université versailles saint quentin
un moment en particulier port du masque
obligatoire gel hydroalcoolique partout
et notamment à la bibliothèque
universitaire le point avec célia gars
de son go il était un peu déboussolé ce
matin après six mois de cours à la
maison
les étudiants de la faculté de droit ont
retrouvé les bancs des amphis oui ça
fait depuis mars qu'on n'est pas allé en
cours et leur revenir en en chine avec
une place sur deux même les amphis moins
bondée savez ça fait bizarre même avec
les yeux on a eu du coup une nouvelle un
nouveau truc imposé par la fac échec du
coup on est en semaine à semaine b les
amphis sont divisées par deux dons
précise spécial ben il ya toujours quand
même cette petite pointe d'appréhension
de se dire qu'on est énormément dans
cette fac et que forcément il y aura des
quatre coronavirus mais globalement
sinon ça va en tout le monde à le
masquer
il ya tout le temps du gel à disposition
pédagogique nous allons mettre en oeuvre
ce devait être mais moi d'aller de
spécifique
c'était la rentrée aussi pour cette
professeur de droit devant elle deux
cents étudiants au lieu de 400 pour
respecter les distanciation social c'est
une nouvelle organisation à mettre en
place et nous les enseignants nous
allons faire ce qu'on appelle des
enseignements hybride c'est-à-dire qui
aura une partie de cours dans lequel
nous accueillerons un petit groupe en
présentiel et puis une partie de cours à
distance et le système est conçu pour qu
il y ait une forme de rotation
son cours est désormais filmer pour
permettre aux autres étudiants de suivre
à distance ses équipes et ils ont ces
derniers mois on a équipé ont été assez
peu équipés d'outils numériques soit de
moyens de captation vidéo ou d'outils de
webconférence déjà c'est le premier
point est le deuxième fois ci une
attention particulière sur les ce qu'on
appelle les étudiants primo-entrants ces
néo bacheliers pour faire en sorte de
les accueillir eux de les prioriser pour
les accueillir en présence hier à la
bibliothèque universitaire impossible
d'accueillir tous les étudiants
d'habitude la bibliothèque compte 1100
places assises dorénavant seulement 500
seront proposés et les étudiants devront
les réserver ils sont aussi obligés de
réserver via une application influence à
l'avance comme ça ça nous permet aussi
éventuellement un traçage de savoir qui
est rentré dans la bibliothèque fini
aussi les travaux en groupe
les salles sont désormais individuelles
et les 10000 livres empruntés à
l'extérieur seront à leur tour mises en
quarantaine pendant trois jours une
rentrée particulière mais aussi
perturbée en raison du coc vide 19 en
fin de semaine dernière on comptait à 90
classes fermées dans toute l'académie de
versailles
une vingtaine rien que dans les yvelines
toutes concernées par des cas positifs
parmi les enfants ou les équipes
enseignantes
le rectorat sûr que la continuité
pédagogique est bien assurée pour les
élèves contraints de rester chez eux
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également les crs de la
direction zonale de vélizy-villacoublay
ont un nouveau dirigeant c'est une femme
c'est une première pour ce groupement
pascal regnauld dubois été
officiellement installé vendredi dernier
une cérémonie en présence de gérald
darmanin et de la ministre déléguée
marlène schiappa le ministre de
l'intérieur a profité de son discours
pour faire des annonces il a exprimé sa
volonté de diminuer le nombre de
violences lors de manifestations qui
touchent les forces de l'ordre où les
citoyens et a notamment affirmé que
chaque tir de l bd ses lanceurs de
balles de défense sera désormais soumis
à l'accord d'un superviseur un mot de
sport avec le retour de la fête du vélo
le week-end dernier à montigny le
bretonneux au programme quatre circuits
pendant trois jours dont un qui était
adressé aux familles le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et de nicolas
landry c'est une tradition à montigny le
bretonneux comme lors de chaque rentrée
le vélo club de la ville organise sa
fête du vélo du 11 au 13 septembre
quatre circuits vtt sont proposées au
public ce samedi des courses loisirs
dont 1 18 et 1 25 km étaient au
programme
le parcours donc le bois du manet
changarnier domaines port royal et ils
vont avoir ravitaillement qui va se
situer à mi parcours à peu près une
quinzaine de kilomètres où ils vont
pouvoir se restaurer un petit bois sont
un petit sachet sucré et après ils
reviendront ici où ils recevront une de
nouveau une petite collation pour finir
la journée
cette année pour cette 28e édition 4 120
coureurs se sont inscrits pour
participer au rendez-vous loisirs du
samedi malgré les conditions sanitaires
du moment hyper important de toute façon
j'avais pratiquement tous les ans je
suis un abonné à cette journée
sympathique et donc je
tous les ans il ya deux ou trois ans la
dernière fois qu'on avait fait cette
course on était fini on avait terminé
bon dernier
parce qu'on avait pris beaucoup de
plaisir à
à regarder le paysage et à vivre
vraiment cette beauté dans le 78 donc
depuis je retourne avec mon ami qui me
traîne souvent j'aime bien rouler avec
le vélo c'est drôle qu'on ne doit forer
à faire des bosses partout et
aller en forêt un vélo c'est forcément
écolo et faire des randonnées un pas
puis le dimanche le rendez-vous a
affiché complet 500 sportifs se sont
élancés sur des raids compétition de 62
à 75 km rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition
et d'ailleurs ne manquez pas ce soir le
retour du 7-8 sport sur tv 60,18
l'émission de la rédaction pour revenir
sur les résultats des clubs yvelinois du
week end
le rendez vous est fixé à 18h30 avec
michael et demi d'euros à maurepas le
week end était consacrée au moyen-âge la
ville était à l'heure médiévale avec une
traditionnelle fête désormais puisqu'il
s'agissait de la troisième édition deux
jours d'événements sur lesquels revient
astrid bergère les morlaisiens ont pu
revivre quelques siècles en arrière avec
la fête médiévale organisée ce week-end
pour la troisième fois des passionnés
organisé un complot traditionnels et des
animations
alors aujourd'hui notre atelier on peut
donc reconstruire notre dame de paris on
peut travailler sur les autres on a fait
des lettrines et des marque pages aux
ocres et on peut aussi reconstruire
l'abbaye de la chaise dieu
le samedi soir l'histoire de la commune
au moyen-âge a été racontée aux
visiteurs notamment à travers la chute
de son château laville même aujourd'hui
garde un lien très fort avec cette
période
maurepas à son village médiéval avec la
tour l'église ya vraiment un village
qu'est moyenâgeuse qui date de
de l'an mil à peu près enfin je
raccourcis un peu mais c'est ça donc
voilà oui il ya une petite et gagna une
histoire mort pas yens cet événement
attire beaucoup pour la seule journée de
samedi plus de 2000 personnes sont
venues notamment cette famille habitant
à maurepas depuis 20 ans on est venus
l'année dernière donc cette année on est
on est super contents parce qu'il ya
plus d'exposants que l'année dernière il
ya eu un magnifique spectacle
hier soir également avec une embrasement
de tours fait part par le service
technique
c'était vraiment magnifique pour
terminer ce journal la page dédiée à la
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines les
électeurs sont appelés aux urnes pour le
premier tour le dimanche 20 septembre
éventuel deuxième tour le dimanche 27
septembre un scrutin rendu nécessaire
après la démission de nadia est entré au
gouvernement on scande ida sont en lice
les noms qui sont affichées à l'écran et
parmi eux valérie froberger qui est en
lice pour la france insoumise et le
parti communiste présentation un nouveau
combat politique pour valérie froberger
l'aide soignante responsable syndical et
militante communiste est candidate dans
la 11e circonscription
thibault langlois comme suppléant pour
cette législative partielle ou la france
insoumise et le parti communiste parti
allié une campagne tournée vers la
défense des services publics le climat
ainsi que l'urgence sociale et
économique
pendant la période du confinement on a
bien on a bien vu que les petites
entreprises les petites associations les
coopératives ont terriblement souffert
et auraient fragilisé pendant cette
période
et malheureusement elles n'ont pas reçu
une aide de l'état et donc service à les
amener en grande difficulté des
difficultés attendent que la candidate
est venu recueillir sur le terrain
vendredi 11 septembre près de plusieurs
acteurs et associations locales une
visite accompagné de la députée de la
france insoumise danièle obono
aujourd'hui il ya besoin d'avoir à
l'assemblée nationale des élus des
parlementaires qui mène
une bataille acharnée pour répondre aux
besoins de la situation on est en pleine
crise sanitaire encore et la crise
économique et sociale qui est en cours
pour autant la gauche ne fera pas front
commun à l'élection la conseillère
régionale et première adjointe de
trappes sandrine grand gang part de son
côté pour génération et europe ecologie
les verts ont navré pour le
rassemblement des forces de gauche et
territoires en organisant à notre
initiative plusieurs réunions et de
discussions on trouve tout simplement
regrettable qu'on n'ait pas pu se mettre
à trouver un accord valérie froberger se
dit encore ouverte aux discussions pour
un éventuel rassemblement face aux deux
candidatures de gauche neuf autres sont
en lice pour cette législative partielle
est avec moi en plateau une autre
candidate je vais en parler dans le
reportage sandrine grand gant de bonsoir
d'être conseil régional première
adjointe de la ville de trappes et vous
porter la candidature commune de
génération votre formation avec europe
ecologie les verts vous est également
soutenue par le parti socialiste à votre
suppléant et le militant écologiste
nicolas farik est engagée à saint cyr
l'école
il y aura donc on le disait de
candidatures de gauche pour cette
législative partielle des discussions
ont eu lieu mais la france insoumise et
le parti communiste affirme que vous ne
leur avait pas apporté de réponse est ce
que les discussions pourquoi les
discussions n'ont pas abouti
là on a deux versions différentes et ça
n'intéresse pas beaucoup notre
tambouille interne à mon avis vos
téléspectateurs
moi je regrette effectivement qui est
pas d'union c'est une stratégie de pc la
france insoumise mais c'est pas grave on
travaille ensemble
la trappe sans difficulté donc voilà je
suis confiante sur le fait que de toute
façon les forces de gauche ont vocation
à se rassembler donc se rassemblent et
peut-être dans un éventuel deuxième tour
si d'aventuré il ya une qualification
d'une des deux listes pour le deuxième
tour où exactement ça fait partie des
choses que l'on espère c'est important
de porter aussi des combats communs donc
je pense que c'est le cas
un des points de blocage quand même pour
vous dire ce qui nous dans la discussion
a été compliquée c'est que on a souffert
pendant
les trois dernières années d'avoir un
député qui est une député fantôme et il
se trouve que indépendamment des
qualités la candidate du pcl l ai pas
dit si les pas de certaines
constructions donc nous c'est quelque
chose qui n'était pas possible il faut
quelqu'un qui soit ancré sur ce
territoire
vous parlez de mahdia qui a été élue du
coup de 2017 à 2020 elle a démissioné
puisqu'elle est entrée au gouvernement
vous qui avait été lui aussi dans la
précédente majorité attrape il n'y a pas
eu assez de travail mené avec la députée
ce que vous regrettez trail du tout si
elle n'était pas là elle était pas été
présente du tout sur le territoire nord
est et est peut-être ailleurs j'en sais
rien mais un député c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui doit être en lien avec la
population qui doit être au contact des
réalités de ce que vivent aussi les gens
donc pour ça il faut être présent
et justement alors vous avez des mandats
au niveau local vous êtes je disais
conseiller régional également premier
adjoint de la ville de trappes c'est
pour ça que vous avez envie de porter
cette candidature c'est de mettre à
profit cette expérience acquise acquis
sur le terrain
oui puis c'est moi c'est une
circonscription que je connais bien je
connais bien l'ensemble des villes
particulièrement trappe qui est la ville
la plus importante de cette
circonscription est et on voit bien que
il ya énormément de choses à faire il ya
des problématiques communes que ce soit
la question des transports
que ce soit la question de la protection
d'environnement on a apporté ensemble
des projets forts sur cette
circonscription est donc c'est pourquoi
mon expérience le cacher c'est un jeu
pour elle à la mettre à profit justement
les projets à porter à l'assemblée
nationale vous en parliez les transports
il ya l'urgence climatique et sociale ça
c'est le point on va dire sur lequel
vous voulez insisté là on l'a vu dans
votre reportage au tout début les gens
ont bien conscience que ce qu'on vive à
sur le plan climatique est quelque chose
d'assez anormal et que même s'il fait
très chaud très beau que c'est agréable
on est là au coeur d'un
d'un problème environnemental qui est
devant nous et il faut changer de modèle
de société et donc la candidature que je
porte et qui est soutenu par benoît
hamon c'est ça c'est de d'être en
capacité d'inventer demain un nouveau
modèle et puis de porter aussi dès
maintenant les questions urgentes de là
parce qu'on voit bien là aussi période
absolument normal on est en plein dans
une crise économique et sanitaire d'une
ampleur qu'on a jamais connu et il faut
dès maintenant avoir des réponses
concrètes mais on ne disait pas
d'alliance de la gauche total mais il ya
quand même cette alliance avec europe
ecologie les verts ça a été facile de
trouver des points d'entente avec le
avec le parti benoît hamon a depuis
longtemps au sein de génération porter
la question environnementale qui est une
question essentielle pour nous et moi la
région je travaille avec les conseils
régionaux d'europe écologie et les verts
on est dans le même groupe
donc c'est quelque chose qui s'est fait
tout à fait naturellement alors si vous
êtes élu député
demain sur sur cette mandature vous
devrez laisser votre votre poste de
première adjointe de trappes ce qu'on
peut pas cumuler députée et première
être maire adjointe et vous devrez aussi
choisir entre l'un de vos trois mandats
ca tue ou seriez députée conseillère
régionale et conseillère municipale
il faudrait laisser l'inde est un des
deux mandats c'est une bonne chose et
moi je vous ai dit ancrage local c'est
essentiel je vis à trappes je milite à
trappes je porte mes combats politiques
sur cette ville donc c'est évident pour
moi que je resterai conseillère
municipale ça aussi beaucoup de choses
en étant conseillère municipale et
j'accompagnerai c'est le cas échéant
l'équipe qui fait énormément de choses
dans dans ses projets en étant à
l'assemblée nationale ça veut dire vous
allez laisser votre mandat de conseiller
régional
on termine sur aussi le contexte un peu
particulier de cette campagne qui est
menée dans ce contexte d'épidémie
on vous a suivi un reportage qui sera
diffusé demain dans le journal on vous a
suivi c'est difficile d'aller à la
rencontre des trappistes des électeurs
de cette 11e circonscription avec avec
le masque est ce que c'était pas de le
projet là pour le match aussi
enseignante et voilà on a pris
l'habitude de faire cours avec le masque
d'avoir d'en face de nous des élèves sur
l'essai qui ont aussi masse donc on
s'habitue caen n'a pas le choix mais par
contre il faut être très précautionneux
donc pas de réunion publique moi que
c'est très étonné que des candidats
fassent des réunions publiques sauf
c'est pas très sérieux dans la période
le limiter au maximum aussi le porte à
porte plutôt privilégier les pieds
d'immeubles c'est ce que l'on fait et
puis essayer d'avoir d'autres moyens de
communication par les réseaux sociaux et
puis vous êtes là vous faites votre rôle
aussi de pour informer les gens qui à
une élection qu'il ya beaucoup ne savent
toujours pas que on vote parce que c'est
assez inattendu est inhabituel c'est une
12ème circonscription n'a pas l'habitude
de se mobiliser en tout cas pour le vote
on vote on sait que depuis quelques
temps les crétins sont de plus en plus
l'abstention est de plus en plus forte
en plus dans une période où on a fait
campagne fin de l'été plus le coc vide
voilà c'est évidemment compliqué d'avoir
d'espérer une forte participation donc
vraiment je lance un appel pour que les
gens n'oublient pas d'aller voter se
mobilisent viennent avec leurs proches
il fera beau ben ça sera la balade du
dimanche pour aller faire son acteur de
sites web
je le rappelle vous porter la
candidature commune de génération et
d'europe écologie les verts merci et
sandrine grand d'être passé en plateau
premier tour je le rappelle le dimanche
20 septembre un éventuel deuxième tour
le dimanche 27 septembre et puis
toujours dans le cadre de cette campagne
à la législative partielle jeudi dernier
philippe benassaya candidats de la
droite et du centre était en meeting à
saint cyr l'école accompagné de son
suppléant othman das roux le maire de
bois d'arcy a reçu le soutien de gérard
larcher le président du sénat pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines et la
sénatrice sophie primas qu'ils étaient
tous les trois
sur place prochaine réunion publique le
jeudi 17 septembre 20h à la verrière
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi je vous rappelle ce
rendez vous ce soir le retour du 7-8
sport c'est à partir de 18h30 pour faire
un retour sur les résultats sportifs du
week end quant à nous on se retrouve dès
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]